it's just saying like you're saying you
got called fat when you were younger so
now you're going to call someone else
fat is trying to make them feel bad i
feel like that i'm just like it's not to
make them it's not no no it's not to
make them feel bad or you know maybe
maybe they should feel bad enough to get
on the treadmill and run
that's what i did i ran out of money i'm
looking like i swear to god i hit i had
200 pounds you know what i hit 200
pounds it was the worst day of my life
and some dude at work like they were
saying oh i would never date a girl over
200 pounds and i and i and i carry the
weight better so like i'm taller right
so i don't think he knew i was and
and so i signed up for a marathon i
swear to god i ran a marathon
then i lost
and i lost a bunch of weight why so you
sign up bro because because i'm not lazy
because i was like oh [ __ ] this is a
problem and then you know what we do
instead we say you're not a whale
you look great you're not fat even
though that's it is what it is
and you deserve love that's the worst
one everyone deserves love
no one deserves that
we do need to strike a balance story you
don't think you deserve all right you
earn it you don't deserve anything in
life but what do you what do you think
men deserve then if if they still
deserve love everywhere
i feel like what is the guy what is the
guy that approached you what does he
deserve love did you know why didn't you
give it to him i said to him i said to
him i said to him because baby he's not
for me i said to him in my dad's accent
as well so funny i said to him so many
times in the nicest way listen bro i'm
not interested i have a boyfriend you
seem like you're a nice person i'm not
interested yet please leave me alone if
you say that to someone a few times and
they're still not getting it you know
what wait do you hear that it's the
world's small smallest violin
[Laughter]
the guy is running with you
let's not tell you that he likes you
he's 54. how many guys wrote that's even
more impressive
running with you in the morning running
with you my dude's putting in shifts
listen where's the love
that's borderline abuse like if a 54
year old was jogging with me just to say
yo you look good bro even if this gay
guy is doing that thank you my dude
thank you
do you think you have pretty privilege
i think all women to an extent have
pretty privilege
yeah yeah yeah do you think do you think
whales have pretty privilege
[Laughter]
you think you think wales is a very nice
do you think whales have the same amount
of pretty privilege that you have as in
the ones in the ocean
is that what we're talking about i'm
talking about fair checks nah i'm not
talking i'm not calling them that okay
why can't i call them what they are why
do you you
will shut up no i'm saying like why do
you want to live in delusion because
they're fat they have more fat they have
more fat
i'll tell you why you're gonna live in a
delusion it minimizes accountability you
can be offended and it can be plausible
at the same time or it can be
accomplished i feel like i feel like you
can carry weight in a completely
different way and it will look different
on different people like there's guys
right like it's like you said you're
tall who looks like you carried through
who carried 200 pounds on you and you
still didn't look like you were that big
no i was kind of wailing it so
how much does your boyfriend weigh
when people are just like
plus size thing is like why don't you
marry your plus-sized person he's like
96kg i don't know what kg is i don't
know what pounds is it you were saying
200. i was like i don't know what that
is
that in stone kind of thing yeah
what's that so that means he weighs more
than you yeah he weighs more than me
he's a bigger guy
so that goes to that goes to show what
i'm saying what that
um
uh fat woman that you don't like to hear
look at the celeb i mean celebs got a
fat uh girlfriend
i think it depends on who doesn't what
i'm gonna characterize as fat
because if we're talking if we're
talking about fat yeah there's a load of
girls 300 fat asses and you'd be like
yeah 300 where's the fat is it in the
booty show me the name one girl that
looks good at 300 pounds i don't know
what 300 pounds is see i'm going to use
the word obesity you know what 300
pounds is you know what a fat goal is
yeah what is that in stone
what is 300 pounds in its own isn't that
like 150 percent yeah 300
pounds
what is that like is that over
oh it's 21 stone 21 yeah name one girl
that looks good at 21 stone
that's not a whale i don't know anyone
at 21 stone
in media i can think of a lot of plus
size models i don't know does lizard
look good because you never look i think
she's cute
personally i think she's cute
is that yes or no
i think do you think most men want to
screw her
i don't know what most men do do you
think do you think she gets the same
pretty privilege you do
i don't know i don't know i think you do
know that you didn't know i think i
think i think if she was sat next to you
when your boyfriend introduced himself
to you i think you'd have felt pretty
confident
listen
yo i i have a twin sister right so i i
had seen growing up she's actually wait
she used to bully me for a bit cuz i was
like a hippie nice guy when i was
growing up i was like no state it's no
ego whatever but um
i i had the privilege of actually
hearing what women actually think like
women women don't say the truth on
purpose when they get together when they
talk with each other that's when they
say the truth that's then they say why
they get with this guy what they like
about that guy
do you do you think you want to keep
them fat so you don't have to compete
with them
like subconsciously yeah the other girls
right compete with who though like why
you don't think you've got competition
yeah do you think you have no
competition i don't want to compete with
like why am i competing with them anyway
like it's not like it's not life or
death you know you don't think you have
to compete for a man not really
that's a privilege okay well i'll take
that but if there's less wales it might
not be awarded to you no because just as
i said just lucky for you lucky for you
there's a lot of girls plumping
themselves up right now so just being in
shape you're like a juicy go look at
look at you're you're in the top like 30
just not being fat
there's nothing wrong with a girl that's
got a bit of back like it's fine no it's
just yeah there's nothing wrong yeah
there's nothing wrong with a galaxy i
think it's not i think it's not the back
i think it's like the gut the armpit fat
but
it's just not healthy the the
you know when they got like the little
beanie bag on their stomach
like the
the human bean bag on their stomach
that's messed up man
like for me like when people normalize
this it's just like it's not healthy
they're gonna die young yeah
that's not good like i don't know why
people are like letting them die
i had a woman come on that say obesity
is suicide yeah obesity suicide
so like but i'm not forcing someone to
be fat right but you're but you're
saying it's you're you're supporting it
you might as well do because it's
important
you're normalizing it i'm not i care
about them enough to call them a whale
to motivate them to save their life wow
i i should be a hero right now
i
give her a whale ribbon right now i'm
i'm motivating them to get on the
treadmill look at it
if you love someone you tell them the
truth
ah yeah that's true that's very true i
think society has kind of dumbed things
down and made it so that everything is
okay do you do whatever you want but
trying to eliminate the consequences
but how like how it's not being able to
walk okay yeah it's not okay at all
diabetes
diabetes we should motor because for
example i run a football academy right
and there are people if they are
overweight the way i would approach it i
wouldn't immediately say you know you're
fat no i would take them and then i will
show them that you overweight i will
clearly explain it
but it won't hold on but it won't be a
case of me because obviously it's not
going to it's going to demotivate my
demand yeah exactly what i will do is i
will show them the truth
but i will also give them a way to
change that
so but obviously the thing that's wrong
with society right now is that we're
saying oh it's okay for you to just be
like that and keep doing what you're
doing and you deserve love
yeah but what would you do okay
why does one is actually do costs
absolutely
why does someone else have to deal with
your problems because you have so many
health issues and now who's going to
take care of you the guy that's in shape
the thinner partner
i ca
and now you're saying they deserve they
deserve to be taking like what do you do
in your old age oh my gosh they have to
deal with like
how are you going to push them around in
a wheelchair when they're 300 pounds
[Laughter]
men don't having the problem turning
amanda as [ __ ] absolutely yeah you tell
you if you've got a fat friend you're
telling you need to go and lose weight
you'd have to tell him
yeah okay and the fat kids that were
bullied
they lost weight and now they're
healthier not all of them oh well
the one what about the ones that like
took it to heart and then
those ones shouldn't reproduce right but
the ones
the ones that did
the ones that were like oh wow
maybe i am fat and actually made a
change and actually improve their diet
improve their health
those those are the ones that are better
for it and they're stronger individuals
mentally but my theory is i don't think
women actually want that to happen i
think i think that they kind of
subconsciously want to destroy
people and each other so i i think they
would rather tell each other that they
all look good because i don't think you
really want the best for each other i
don't i don't think like women sitting
with their fat friend telling her that
oh yeah someone's really gonna love you
for you and like you deserve this and
that instead of telling her what she
needs to know because i know a lot of
women like this and they can lie all day
you know what but they're that i feel
and this is the point that i've been
like this is what i've been saying to
myself in my head i feel like
there seems to be like a lot of like
toxic behavioral traits that are
involved in these situations that you're
playing now and this is why i said like
i grew up different i love my friends we
all look completely different there are
people that are bigger they're
absolutely slimming that's all guilt and
need to be right you're shaming him what
do you mean do you have a fat friend
toxic choice
but i'm not i'm not i'm just saying that
you don't need what you called him to
like what this toxic and so i'm saying
like this is like the the no i'm saying
the
scenarios that he's coming up with
as in saying that like
oh
i was fat and i was bullied like that's
a toxic scenario